So far, all the computation we've done has operated only on numbers,
and in the early days of computing,
people thought of computers as super-powerful calculators for doing computations
like simulating nuclear weapons, computing ballistic tables,
or breaking encryption, which was a little more than just arithmetic,
but still was mostly about counting and doing simple arithmetic.
["Nobody believed that I had a running compiler and nobody would touch it.
They told me computers could only do arithmetic." Grace Hopper]
We saw this quote from Grace Hopper earlier, talking about computers could only do arithmetic,
and this is what people thought about computers in the 1940's and 1950's.
But there's no reason to limit computers to that.
They can operate on any kind of data we want,
and it gets much more interesting when we operate on data besides just numbers.
If we're going to build a search engine, most of the data we want to deal with is not numbers,
it's the letters that are contained in web pages,
and in Python that is what we call a "string."
A string is just a sequence of characters surrounded by quotes.
Here's an example of a string in Python.
It starts with a single quote, has a sequence of characters--
and anything we can type on the keyboard can be in a string--
and ends with another single quote.
The string is the sequence of characters between the single quotes.
If we want, we can use double quotes instead.
If we use double quotes, then the double quote starts the string--
we can have a sequence of characters--
and a double quote that ends the string.
The only requirement is that if we start the string with a single quote,
it has to end with a single quote.
If we start the string with a double quote,
it has to end with a double quote.
That's actually a handy property
because that means we can have the other kind of quote within our string.
The string starts with a double quote--
it contains a single quote inside it--
--but because we started with a double quote that single doesn't end the string.
That single quote is just like another character in the string--
--the string continues until the closing double quote.
So, let's try some things in the Python interpreter.
We can print a string just like we can print a number.
Here I am printing the string 'Hello.'
When we run this, we see the output "Hello"--it's printing "Hello."
We don't see the single quotes as it prints, but we know that it's a string that was printed.
We can print a string with double quotes.
One thing to notice when you enter strings in the interpreter, the color is black now--
since it's an open string it hasn't been finished--
--once I type the final quote, that closes the string; the color changes to blue.
So now when we run this we have two prints, both that print "Hello."
It looks the same both times.
It doesn't matter if we use single quotes or double quotes around our string.
Just to check everyone's paying attention, I'm going to try one more thing.
Now I am printing "Hello" without the quotes.
Try to see if you can guess what that will do--
we won't make a quiz of this--
but try to guess before I run it.
Now that I run this, we see the result:
we get a name error.
The name "Hello" is not defined.
Without the quotes, this [indicating Hello on screen] looks just like a variable.
It's a name, but it's a variable that we didn't define.
So when I try to use it, I get an error that the variable name "Hello" is not defined.
If I wanted to, I could define a variable name "Hello."
Let's make "Hello" refer to the string "Howdy."
[Hello = "Howdy"]
And now when I print "Hello" it works.
I see the first two prints that printed "Hello."
Now when I print the variable "Hello," that refers to the string "Howdy,"
and I see "Howdy" as the result.
We usually don't want our variables to start with capital letters--that's just a convention--
so I'm going to change this back to a lowercase "hello"
because it makes me feel uncomfortable to have a variable with a capital letter.
There's no rule against that in Python,
it's just a convention that we like to follow.